>> MISTER PRESIDENT, YOU'VE
OBVIOUSLY HEARD THERE'S ALL
THESE ARTICLES BEING WRITTEN IN
THESE FOREIGN POLICY ANALYSTS
WHO ARE SAYING ISN'T IT ENOUGH
ALREADY FOR YOU?
SHOULD YOU GO TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE?
ARE YOU FEELING ANY PRESSURE
YOU GO TO THE NEGOTIATION TABLE?
>> LOOK, THEY DON'T WANT THIS
WAR TO BE FINISHED.
NOW, BEFORE HAVING ANY FATIGUE,
EVERYONE HAS TO UNDERSTAND THAT
IT'S ONLY THE KREMLIN, AND ONLY
ONE PERSON, THE HEAD OF THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION, WHO IS NOT
TIRED OF THE WAR.
HE MIGHT BE TIRED OF LIFE IN
PRINCIPLE BECAUSE OF HIS AGE,
BUT HE'S DEFINITELY NOT TIRED
OF THE WAR.
THIS PERSON AND THE RUSSIAN
POLITICAL AND MILITARY
LEADERSHIP NEED A PAUSE.
BELIEVE ME, THEY CAN FEEL IT.
THEY'VE BEGUN TO FIELD THE
EFFECT OF THESE ACTIONS.
THEY HAVE BEGUN TO FEEL
DISSATISFACTION IN THEIR
SOCIETY.
THIS PERSON AND ALL OF THEM ARE
AFRAID OF OUR SOCIETY.
THESE PEOPLE UNFORTUNATELY HAVE
NO VOICE.
BECAUSE IF THEY WEREN'T AFRAID
OF GOING TO THE STREETS, THEY
WOULD EXERT PRESSURE.
THIS IS WHAT THE RUSSIAN
LEADERSHIP IS A PARADE OF.
AND THEN FOR OUR PART, WE SAY
PLEASE RESPECT OUR PRINCIPLES
OF UN CHARTER.
PLEASE RESPECT OUR TERRITORIAL
INTEGRITY.
PLEASE RESPECT OUR RIGHT, OUR
FREEDOM, OUR LAND, AND OUR
CHOICE.
THAT'S IT.
SO THIS WORD FATIGUE IS A BIG
WORD.
YOU CAN'T GET FATIGUED.
IT'S TOO EARLY FOR ALL OF US TO
GET FATIGUED.
BUT THE WIND RUSSIA TRULY WANTS
PEACE, WE WILL DEFINITELY FEEL
IT AND SEE THAT.
YOU KNOW, YOU CAN'T WISH FOR
PEACE WITH WORDS ALONE.
WORDS ARE NOT ENOUGH.
STOP THE WAR, WITHDRAW FROM THE
TERRITORY, STOP KILLING PEOPLE.
START REIMBURSING THE DAMAGES
INFLICTED ON OUR COUNTRY.
CRIMINALS MUST BE PROSECUTED SO
WORDS ARE NOT ENOUGH.
>> DO YOU STILL STAND BY WHAT
YOU SAID A FEW MONTHS AGO?
THAT YOU WOULD NOT COULD --
NEGOTIATE WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN?
>> HIS PROPOSAL HAS NO
SUBSTANCE WITH REGARDS OF
ENDING THE WAR.
OTHER THAN THE ULTIMATUMS, I'VE
NOT HEARD ANYTHING FROM THE
CURRENT PRESIDENT OF THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
STARTING FOR THE 24TH OF
FEBRUARY, THERE HAVE BEEN ONLY
ULTIMATUMS.
DENAZIFICATION, THE
NATIONALIZATION, EVERY ISSUE
THEY RAISE STARTS WITH THE.
THEY ALWAYS WANT TO DEPRIVE US
OF SOMETHING VIOLENTLY ON OUR
OWN LAND.
SO I SAID I'M NOT GOING TO TALK
TO THIS PERSON IF THIS PERSON
CONDUCTS THESE SHAM REFERENDUMS
AND RECOGNIZES ALL OF THESE
SHAM AUTHORITIES THAT THEY SET
UP AS LEGAL.
WE SAID THIS CLEARLY.
I SAID IF THEY DO THAT, THEN
THIS MEANS THEY DON'T RESPECT
OUR PEOPLE, OUR SOVEREIGNTY,
OUR RIGHTS AND OUR FREEDOMS.
WHAT IS THERE TO TALK TO THEM
ABOUT?
BUT I HAVE NOT CLOSED THE DOOR.
I SAID WE WOULD BE READY TO
TALK TO RUSSIA, BUT WITH A
DIFFERENT RUSSIA.
ONE THAT IS TRULY READY FOR
PEACE.
ONE THAT IS READY TO RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY ARE OCCUPIERS.
READY TO REIMBURSE OUR PEOPLE.
THAT'S NOT ABOUT MONEY.
THEY NEED TO RETURN EVERYTHING,
LAND, RIGHTS, FREEDOM, MONEY,
AND MOST IMPORTANTLY JUSTICE.
TO THE PARENTS WHO LOST THEIR
CHILDREN.
MONEY IS NOT ENOUGH.
IT'S NOT A PRIORITY.
BRING BACK JUSTICE.
AND SO FAR, I HAVE NOT HEARD
STATEMENTS LIKE THAT FROM THE
RUSSIAN FEDERATION, EITHER FROM
PUTIN OR FROM ANYONE ELSE.
>> THE ISSUE OF NATO IS VERY --
--
A VERY-CHARGED ONE.
I ASSUME YOU ARE PUTTING NATO
TO THE FUTURE, BUT ARE YOU
TRYING TO GET, ARE YOU
CONFIDENT YOU WILL GET SECURITY
GUARANTEES?
>> UKRAINE NEEDS SECURITY
GUARANTEES.
THE WORLD NEEDS SECURITY
GUARANTEES FOR UKRAINE, BECAUSE
STABILITY DEPENDS ON IT.
AND THIS RELATES TO THE 50 YOU
MENTIONED.
AFTER VICTORY, AFTER PEACE, WE
DON'T WANT TO COME BACK TO THE
SAME SITUATION.
BUT IT MIGHT HAPPEN.
THE CURRENT MILITARY AND
POLITICAL LEADERSHIP OF RUSSIA
AND ONE FORM OF ANOTHER, JUST
LIKE THE MIDST AGREEMENT, OR
SOME OTHER AGREEMENTS.
THEY NEEDED A PAUSE.
THEY WILL GATHER UP THEIR
STRENGTH, MONEY, WEAPONS.
THEY WILL GET READY.
THEY WOULD LAY OUT THE
INFORMATION FOR THEIR OWN
SOCIETY, AND WHEN ALL OF THAT
HAS BEEN PREPARED, THEY START
THE OFFENSIVE.
BECAUSE THERE IS ONLY ONE GOAL,
TO DESTROY OUR INDEPENDENCE.
THERE'S NO OTHER GOAL IN PLACE.
THAT IS WHY WE NEED SECURITY
GUARANTEES.
WE ABSOLUTELY WANT THAT.
AND WE BELIEVE WE HAVE ALREADY
DEMONSTRATED OUR FORCES
CAPABILITY TO THE WORLD BY THE
LEVEL OF TRAINING, BY THE
RESILIENCE OF OUR DEFENSE
SYSTEM.
I BELIEVE THAT WE ARE AT THE
SAME LEVEL AS NATO MEMBER
COUNTRIES AT LEAST.
AND I THINK IT WOULD BE FAIR IF
WE WERE IN THE SAME SECURITY
CIRCLE, AND SAME SECURITY
ALLIANCE, BECAUSE THERE ARE NO
WARS AMONG NATO COUNTRIES, OR
INSIDE NATO.
SO FOR US, THIS IS THE MOST
SECURE CONSTRUCT.
BUT IF THAT PART IS LONGER THAN
WE WOULD WANT TO BE,
UNFORTUNATELY DUE TO SOME
PERSONAL ATTITUDES OF THE
LEADERS OF SOME COUNTRIES, I
WOULD AGAIN LIKE TO STRESS THE
LEADERS, NOT THE SOCIETIES,
BECAUSE ALL THE SOCIETIES
DEFINITELY SIDE WITH US.
IF THAT PATH IS LONGER THAN WE
CAN AFFORD, THEN WHILE ON THIS
PATH WE WOULD NEED SECURITY
GUARANTEES TO BE ABLE TO REACH
NATO MEMBERSHIP.
BECAUSE EVERYONE KEEPS SAYING
THAT THE DOOR TO NATO'S OPEN,
BUT WE NEED TO REACH THESE
DOORS.
>> I'M GOING TO ASK YOU THIS,
BECAUSE YOU WENT NOT SO MANY
MONTHS AGO TO THE CONGRESS.
YOU ALSO MET WITH PRESIDENT
BIDEN.
YOU MET WITH THE FIRST LADY.
YOU ACTUALLY SAID, WE NEED
WEAPONS.
SEND US THE WEAPONS.
DO YOU FEEL THAT YOU HAVE THE
WEAPONS NOW TO ACTUALLY WIN?
DO YOU FEEL THAT NATO IS HERE
TO HELP YOU WIN, OR JUST TO
STOP YOU FROM LOSING?
>> I THINK THE PRESIDENT KNOWS
BETTER HOW MUCH MORE WE NEED.
I'M SURE WE NEED MUCH MORE, BUT
AS A CITIZEN OF UKRAINE, AS A
MOTHER AND WIFE, I CAN FEEL
THAT WE NEED IT BECAUSE THE
MUSCLES KEEP COMING.
WHEN THEY STOP COMING, WHEN OUR
PEOPLE STOP DYING IN THEIR BEDS
AND MORNING, I WILL FEEL OKAY
MAYBE THAT'S ENOUGH.
BUT WE CAN'T WAIT FOR RUSSIANS
TO RUN OUT OF THEIR SUPPLIES.
IT WOULD BE WONDERFUL FOR THEM
TO RUN OUT, BUT I GUESS THAT IS
FANTASY.
THAT IS WHY I ASKED TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN, TO PROTECT ALL OF
US.
IT IS HARD TO LIVE UNDER THIS
BURDEN EVERY DAY WHEN YOU DON'T
KNOW WHAT WILL HAPPEN TOMORROW,
WHEN THE MISSILES WILL HIT
CROSSROADS WHILE PEOPLE ARE
DRIVING TO WORK AND GET KILLED
ON THE WAY.
THE OTHER PART OF THAT MISSILE
HIT A CHILDREN'S PLAYGROUND IN
A PARK.
I LITERALLY WALKED THERE WITH
MY CHILDREN WHEN THEY WERE
YOUNG.
I'M REALLY HAPPY THAT IT WAS 8
AM AND THERE WERE NO CHILDREN
YET.
AND I'M HAPPY THAT MY CHILDREN
ARE --
WERE NOT THERE.
BUT IT BRINGS IT CLOSER AND
CLOSER.
SO THE QUESTIONS OF WEAPONS IS
A QUESTION OF OUR SURVIVAL.
THE SURVIVAL OF OUR AND OUR --
US AND OUR CHILDREN.
>> MISTER PRESIDENT, AFTER ALL
OF YOUR POWERFUL CALLS TO THE
WORLD FOR HELP, WEAPONRY MOST
ESPECIALLY, TRAINING, ALL THAT
INTELLIGENCE HELP YOU'VE NEEDED,
ARE THEY FINALLY DELIVERING
WHAT YOU NEED TO WIN?
AND DO YOU FEEL LIKE YOU ARE
GETTING ENOUGH TO WIN, OR JUST
NOT TO LOSE?
>> I THINK MY WIFE ANSWERED IT
VERY WELL.
THE ANSWER IS FAIRLY SIMPLE.
IT IS ENOUGH WHEN YOU CAN NO
LONGER HEAR EXPLOSIONS.
IT'S ENOUGH WHEN THE AIR
DEFENSE SYSTEM ENSURES NO
MISSILES HIT THE GROUND OR
BUILDINGS.
IT IS ENOUGH WHEN YOU ARE NOT
BEING FIRED AT NO MISSILES ARE
LAUNCHED AGAINST YOU.
BECAUSE RUSSIA IS WORKING
TOGETHER WITH ITS PARTNER, IF I
MAY CALL THEM THAT, WITH IRAN.
SINCE OCTOBER, WE HAVE SEEN THE
MUSE AROUND 450 KAMIKAZE DRONES,
ATTACK DRONES, AND RECOGNIZANCE
ATTACK DRONES, KAMIKAZE DRONES,
MISSILES.
OVER THIS TIME, WE'VE HAD OVER
2500 HITS.
THAT'S WITHOUT ARTILLERY.
2500 HITS BY DRONES, EXPLOSIVES,
OR MISSILES.
THAT IS A LARGE NUMBER.
DO WE HAVE ENOUGH DEFENSES?
NO, I DON'T THINK WE HAVE
ENOUGH AT ALL.
IS IT ENOUGH TO MAKE 100 OR
1000 CALLS?
PROBABLY NOT ENOUGH EITHER.
BUT I'M READY TO MAKE 1000
CALLS IF EVERY CALL I MAKE
RESULTS IN MORE AIR DEFENSE
SYSTEMS.
I'M READY TO STAY ON THE PHONE
AND JUST DO THAT.
IT'S DIFFICULT.
A JOINT DECISION ON THE
PROTECTION OF UKRAINE AND
UKRAINIAN AIRSPACE WILL
DEFINITELY HELP US.
AND ALL THE ANSWERS ARE THERE.
I'M SORRY, IT'S NOT EVEN LIKE
THE START OF THE COVID
EPIDEMIC.
WHEN PEOPLE DID NOT KNOW WHAT
TO DO ABOUT IT, WHEN WE NEEDED
TO CREATE THE VACCINE AND IT
DIDN'T EXIST.
THERE IS A VACCINE AGAINST
RUSSIAN STRIKES AND WE KNOW IT.
RUSSIA AND WE KNOW EXACTLY
WHICH COUNTRIES HAVE IT, AND IN
WHAT AMOUNT.
AND I WOULD SAY FRANKLY, THERE
ARE EVEN COUNTRIES THAT HAVE A
SURPLUS AMOUNT FROM MY POINT OF
VIEW.
SO I GUESS IN ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION, THERE IS NOT ENOUGH
WILLINGNESS I WOULD SAY.